Whatever your budget, there's a space trip just for you.
A lot has changed since the first man ventured into space in 1961.
Pluto is no longer a planet,...
...NASA has just announced its new spacecraft named Orion,...
...and space tourism is slowly becoming a reality.
Since 2001, Virginia-based Space Adventures...
...has been selling an eight-day trip to the Space Station...
...round-trip airfare on a Russian shuttle Soyuz included...
...for 20 million dollars.
Four people have taken this trip so far,...
...the most recent being, Anousheh Ansari who...
...created the Ansari X Prize...
...which gave ten million dollars to the first team to build the successful...
...private space rocket,...
...become the first female space tourist.
Conversely a trip on Space Ship Two...
...currently under development...
...will cost just 1% or $200,000 for a quick trip into near space and back.
Space Adventures is also involved...
...in building of a massive spaceport in Singapore.
The Singapore Spaceport will include a museum...
...and a variety of space-related experiences.
Visitors will be able to go through G-force training in a centrifuge...
...or take a simulated space walk in a neutral buoyancy tank.
Playing on zero gravity,...
...the spaceport's structure...
...will be built to look as if it is floating over a pool of water.
The innovative spacecraft,...
...spaceports, and hotels on the drawing board are cause for excitement.
The final frontier may soon be within the reach of more than just...
...professional astronauts and the ultra rich.